uh good evening and uh welcome to this
meeting of traffic council's Planning
and Development Committee my name is
councilor Barry and Stanley and I am the
chair of this committee uh before we
start the meeting proper can I ask if
anybody in the public areas intending to
film the meeting
okay that's fabulous thank you in any
event we are being broadcast on our
council's YouTube channel uh continuing
on to my media writers councilor
Florence Walsh who is vice chair of this
committee to our left and right are
Council officers from planning legal and
highways
down both side of the table are members
of the committee who are all local
councilors I'll introduce them as they
speak
to the agenda item one attendances to
note our attendances as we just have and
to note any apologies we have apologies
this evening from councilor Deacon and
councilor Baba councilor Oxford is after
attending a sub thank you councilor
item two membership of the committee to
note that Council Jerome has replaced
councilor wetton on the planning and
development management committee with
effect from 25th of July
2023. can this be noted members take
that as a yes thank you welcome back
councilor Jerome
item three Declarations of Interest
members to give notice of any personal
or prejudicial interest and the nature
of that interest relating to any item on
the agenda in accordance with the
accepted code of conduct does any member
wish to declare an interest
councilman uh I wish to recuse myself
for uh
page number 5162 Green Drive on the
basis that my word colleague and
friendship lives there so okay thank you
anybody else Mr clear interest
okay I will declare interest on item
108068 Woods End Road I've done case
work already on this issue I'll be
accusing myself for this item and
councilor Walsh will chair that section
of the meeting
item four minutes to receive and if so
determined to approve the correct record
diminishing the meeting held on 13th of
July I could have a proposal please
thank you councilor and a seconder thank
you councilor so those minutes are so
approved item five questions from
members of the public we have no
questions from members of the public
this evening item six additional
information report to consider a report
on the head of Planning and Development
to be tabled at the meeting this report
has been so tabled
item seven applications for permission
to develop to consider the tax report to
the head of planning and development for
the following applications we have three
tonight the process is the same in each
case the item is introduced by a member
of the planning team if we have speakers
on the item then speak next members of
the public for three minutes uh Ward
councilors get five minutes I'll then
open up the item for debate to members
of the committee only and will then go
into a decision based on majority vote
the first item on agenda is 1 10688 is
land off shore Road in irmstone it's on
page three of your pack and Miss Lowe's
we'll get the introduction thank you
Miss Lowe's
thank you chair
[Music]
just bear with me a second the
presentation is um
there we go thank you
this application relates to land at
Shore Road and which is currently
accessed off um pennybridge Lane and is
a vacant piece of land planning
permission is sort for the erection of
12 one bedroom dwellings available for
social rent and the scheme would solely
provide accommodation to support people
out of homelessness and rough sleeping
this site is part of a wider a larger
piece of open land which is currently
used as informal car parking the site is
adjacent to Terrace properties on Shore
View to the north
and the Shoreview Residential Care home
to the east and the Trafford FC football
stadium is to the south of the site
Beyond Shore Road
a couple of photos just to show you
um some views of the site and the first
photograph here is looking north towards
Shoreview from within the um the wider
vacant land and currently uses car
parking
this is a view of the Shore Terrace
Shoreview Terrace properties and the
front access
um alleyway
this is a view of Shoreview and its
relationship with the car park and the
existing landscaping and pennybridge
Lane is just behind the um the
photographer
now this view is on the opposite side of
the site from within the um Shoreview
Residential Care home
um close and complex and this will be
the access road that the the development
is accessed from
and again this is just um further round
within the complex and the majorities
that you see um on on the site on on the
photograph is the area of the
application site
the proposed buildings would building
would be two stories in scale and
constructed in facing brick with
elements of communal and private amenity
space tree planting and Landscaping is
proposed around the site with a brick
wall with Landscaping proposed to the
north and Western boundaries
and you can see the elevational
treatment there with individual and
entrance doors to each of those 12 units
and taking a traditional form in in in
its parents with um fenestration in a
symmetrical pattern
the application is reported to committee
because we've received more than six
representations contrary to the office
of recommendation and the site and
relates to land in the council's
ownership
the majority of the representations cite
the loss of car parking within the area
and the impact on the surrounding
residential amenity
the site and the remained of The Wider
area of the land off pennybridge road is
currently vacant and is used informally
as car parking it's important to note
that this is not a designated Council
car parking car park nor is it managed
as such it is utilized for this use in
the absence of any other formal use
however it is recognized that this
development and and the loss of this
part of the site will will result in
less area of the site for car parking
however this is not the formal car park
for the Trafford FC or any of the other
local community uses which do not
benefit from their own car parking areas
the proposed development is proposed to
be cited perpendicular
go back to the site plan is proposed to
be cited perpendicular to the existing
Terrace at Shoreview and is it somewhat
and is somewhat odds with the urban
Green in the local area
the two-story side game love the
development will be cited 15 meters from
the front elevation of the Shore View
terraced properties there is 7.5 meters
between the boundary of the site and the
um
under the front elevation and 11.5
meters between the single story element
of the proposal and again from that
front elevation
whilst recognize that the development
will result in some massive trees within
the site the development proposes
to retain the strong Landscaping buffer
that currently exists between the
properties at 2 to 24 Shoreview and the
shore of UK home
and that boundary is to remain as as it
currently is additional Landscaping is
proposed on all of the boundaries of the
development site in the form of tree
planting and hedging
as mitigation for this loss as you can
see on the Landscaping plan here a
strong tree line is proposed along the
western boundary and along with brick
wall and hedging and that is followed
around onto the northern boundary
adjacent to the Shoreview properties and
hedging again will be will continue
around on the southern boundary
offices have secured significant
amendments to the development in regards
to its scale massing and appearance and
secured additional landscaping and tree
planting and sought to move the
development away from neighboring
Residential Properties in order to
protect residential amenity however
officers have concerns still regarding
the design of the development however
this is balanced against the substantial
weight which is afforded to the delivery
of the greatly needed affordable homes
specifically though for those who are
homeless
or the detailed matters in terms of
residential amenity Park and Highway
Safety ecology drainage and
contamination are all considered to be
acceptable subject to suitable
conditions
in this regard the Tilted balance is
engaged and in line with national
planning policy framework it is
considered that the adverse impacts of
granting planning permission would not
significantly and demonstrably outweigh
the benefits there are also material
considerations which outweigh the
development plan conflict on this basis
officers are therefore recommending that
the application be approved subject to
conditions thank you chair
well thank you Miss Lowe's we have
several speakers on
um on this item is uh Ms Smith in the
public area
would you care to approach the
microphone you'll have three minutes to
speak uh Miss Smith which will begin
once you press the the button on the
microphone
thank you
hello I'm here representing the
residents of the local community assure
of you and those who have Trafford uh
football club our objection is grounded
in the belief that the development is
inappropriate within its context with
insufficient assessment and incorrect
conclusions having been drawn in respect
for the following reasons one traffic
msv have greatly underrepresented the
development take of car parking spaces
The Proposal States 35 however an aerial
drone shot of the car park that's been
supplied at safe capacity shows 54. this
leads to a parking shortage of Shoreview
residence Trafford FC and seven other
nearby associations and clubs that rely
on this space most of which include
youth participation Trafford FC attracts
an average crowd of 410 on a league day
often exceeding a thousand on higher
profile matches more loss of parking
will only exacerbate parking overflow
forced to nearby unrestricted roads
posing real safety concerns for foot
traffic within the area
should the intensification of a highly
utilized public space be allowed at
worst this could result in the serious
injury or harm to an individual
to safety a youth Community relies upon
the car park for safe passage from both
both Trafford youth FC and urmston
musical theater the nature of this
scheme as it is and its proposed
residents vetted and homeless
post-safety risks for these children
in our opinion it is inappropriate to
place a facility of this nature an
immediate proximity to Shore Road
residential home a facility that houses
very vulnerable adults this again is
another safety safeguarding concern
emergency vehicle access to the front of
Shoreview cottages and to the fire
hydrant will be severely restricted
posing an increased safety concern to
its residents
the formal planning report now
contradicts the intended use of this
accommodation the consultation confirmed
that the successful Grant will be based
on upon offering stability not transient
and short-term homelessness that can
come with some severe challenges
three the impact on Shoreview residents
the latest plans are confirmed not to be
within keeping with the historic nature
of Shoreview Cottages a violation of
planning Guidance the proposed
development boundaries are within a
seven meter distance of Shoreview and
approximately 10 meter distance from the
front doors of six Cottages causing a
significant impact to natural light and
privacy of these properties and more our
soul viewers will now become a brick
wall
all sure for you south facing front
Gardens are heavily used by its
residents including children The
Cottages rely on this as their own outs
only outside space so overshadowing this
has a significant impact on our quality
of life
the current plans block a main access
point to Shoreview impacting the safety
of those Reliant upon wheelchairs
mobility scooters prams and Buggies
these residents Who currently Park in
the car park would now have to access
their properties via pennybridge Lane
which does not include Pavements and is
often overgrown and therefore blind to
um due to poor upkeep of surrounding
trees
substantial noise and air pollution
during the proposed Health months of
construction will be disruptive to us
and have a detrimental impact to local
wildlife in particular the bat
population contrary to regulation
I also note that subsequent to a
dismissive response raised formally to
Trafford Council a complaint as to the
fundamental undemocratic consultation
process could you now come to the end
your remarks please
okay thank you thank you
we now have a statement from councilor
Thomas which will be read by Miss Coley
thank you Miss Kelly thank you chair
just just for members in The public's
information
um
the this statement has five minutes if I
don't manage to complete any of the
statements this evening within the time
available I will just round up and
finish where I've got to
thank you
um okay so this is a statement on behalf
of councilor Thomas as a council we have
responsibility to ensure that the
development in any Community maintains
the amenity of the community it serves
the officers report on this application
clearly states that it does not meet
requirements in design location nor does
it in any way enhance the community in
which is being proposed in fact the
Gable end of the building will be 7.5
meters from six of the cottages on the
Terrace the impact on loss of daylight
to all residents of this south facing
Terrace would be hugely detrimental with
all suffering loss of light at some
stage in the day the six properties
being impacted throughout daylight hours
and left with a brick wall as the
Outlook from their windows
access to the unadopted pathway situated
in the Terrace garden areas has one
accessible point which is to be blocked
by the perimeter of this plan meaning
residents and visitors using disability
vehicles and children's buggies will
have no access to the homes and will
need to Traverse around the perimeter of
the site to access the residence path on
Shore Road
there is no mention of the parking area
reserve for residents which was woefully
inadequate yet promised at consultation
watered down and seemingly removed from
the plans
the number of spaces lost to this site
is 54 minimum knots 35 combined with the
completely inaccurate traffic survey by
the applicant confirmed by my visits and
the number of photographs and drone
videos shown in the representations
showing the massive over subscription of
the car park on every match day the
local already full residential streets
would be further loaded with on-street
parking worsening the existing danger to
pedestrians using Chason Park and also
two Local Schools who ask parents to use
the car park at drop-off and pickup
times to alleviate the dangers caused by
on-street parking it is a major
detriment to a community that houses two
Community clubs Trafford FC with 415
registered youth players as well as open
Age teams and a facility that over a
thousand children use by way of training
courses and youth tournaments from
across greater Manchester
and to the musical theater a
long-running group is well supported
locally and aspire to their own theater
in the future and chasing part one of
the largest children's parks play Space
a Miniature Railway in the borough
all of these Community assets rely on
the car parking facilities where the
plan building is proposed
there are no car parking spaces
associated with the scheme meaning that
any Resident would add to the issue and
does not comply with the 0.5 maximum per
domicile associated with development it
is assumed residents will not have
vehicles
this scheme seriously hampers access to
emergency vehicles via the single track
pennybridge Lane the only Route 22 to 38
Shoreview Terrace fire engines have had
difficulties reaching properties and
should an accidental Health Emergency
occur there would be little or no access
for ambulances to the residents football
club and the golf course when the car
park is full
this application misses the criteria for
approval in so many different aspects
and is only just scraping through on the
use of the Tilted balance
the Tilted balance for decision making
states do not Grant if any adverse
impacts of doing so would significantly
in demonstrably outweigh the benefits
paragraph 11d2 of the mppf the very
negative impact on the roads will deter
use of the facilities within 200 meters
of the development
the first paragraph of the summary
regarding the use quote supporting
homelessness and rough sleepers yet
paragraph 21 states the aims are to
provide single short-term occupancy
apartments for people in hostels after
betting by host or msv it is not clear
as to who does the vetting this is not
part of the bed every night scheme and
the funding precludes it from such a use
there are bats under the wildlife
evidence on the site the site is 30
yards from the former William Rowe Golf
Course recently breaching fields and
Trust status and there's nothing of the
impact of the wildlife on the course
the officer States the development will
be on Congress poor design and
completely fails to match the urban
grain this committee has refused
applications that failed to meet just
one of the above requirements previously
as with every point in the abysmal
consultation period the recent extension
only reached out to an alleged 50
properties already a complaint is being
raised about the process
paragraph 43 identifies conflict with L7
and the council pg-1 supplementary
document stating the design of the
building is disappointing and does not
Accord with the aspirations set out in
the traffic design code consultation
draft a reason for refusal in its own
right this is a panic plan put together
too quickly with no little or no
examination of sustainability of the
local area to cope with the many
detrimental impacts thank you chair
thank you Miss Coley before I go back to
the officers to ask for some response to
the points raised in uh in their
representations uh we'll now go finish
the rest of the speakers uh is Miss
O'Connor in the public area
thank you Mr O'Connor it's the same
Drillers before as you've seen so you'll
get three minutes to speak uh beginning
once you press the button on the
microphone
thank you
Rachel O'Connor from Moscow some
Vincent's apologies
scheme will provide much needed
accommodation for those who have been
made homeless or experienced rough
sleeping in Trafford and are looking to
take their next step towards independent
living and a permanent tenancy
the scheme is for people with low level
support needs who've been successful in
emergency accommodation and are engaging
well with other Support Services the
people in this scheme will be taking
steps to improve their lives and we
anticipate that tenants will remain in
the accommodation for around about two
years
each tenancy will be allocated via host
trafford's homelessness team who will
vet and allocate support workers to
individuals host will have the final say
on any selection
msv has established a strong track
record in developing and managing
move-on accommodation for homeless
people
we will provide day-to-day housing
management and maintenance services and
we will work in partnership with shared
habitat a bespoke property management
company who will in turn provide
additional tenancy management and
support
in terms of the scheme design msv has
worked with btp Architects and we've
worked very closely with the council's
officers to develop the scheme presented
today
the following has been discussed and
agreed with officers to minimize the
impact on existing buildings and impact
to Neighbors
the proposed scheme has taken its design
precedent from Shoreview Terrace in
terms of form materials and detailing
the scheme has been carefully designed
to reduce and negate impact on Neighbors
all apartments have been designed to
exceed nationally described space
standards
height and massing has been designed to
minimize the impact on existing
dwellings
separating distances are in line with
Trafford council's guidelines new trees
will be planted to mitigate the trees
removed for the development and each new
tree will be carefully selected to
ensure longevity and new Hedges will be
planted along the car park side to
soften the new boundary wall proposed
each resident will have access to
external space and the scheme is
designed with sustainability in mind
the fabric first approach to meet and
exceed current building regulations
cycle storage will be provided for every
resident on the scheme as well
all statutory consulties have commented
and all concerns have been addressed
the project has received an allocation
of grant funding from the Department of
leveling Up's rough sleeping
accommodation program
if planning permission is granted msv
would commence the works at the earliest
opportunity following the discharge of
any pre-commencement planning conditions
we would urge you to consider the
significance of this scheme to support
homelessness within the borough it's
been carefully designed to minimize the
impact on existing Trafford residents
and offers an opportunity to existing
and future residents to improve their
lives immeasurably and as a committee I
ask you therefore to support the
application
thank you
ah thank you Ms O'Connor and we also
have a statement from Council writer
which will be read out by
Miss Coley thank you
thank you a statement on behalf of
councilor James Wright executive member
for housing and advice thank you chair
for allowing me the opportunity to write
in favor of this application I'm sorry I
cannot physically be at the meeting but
unfortunately work commitments have
prevented this I write in support of
this application not just as the member
responsible for housing and Trafford but
also as a resident of this Borough
Trafford has one of the most acute
housing crises in the country we have
one of the lowest proportions of social
housing stock in Greater Manchester the
highest cost privately rented
accommodation in Greater Manchester when
taking out the city center and some of
the most expensive house prices in the
country the average home in Trafford is
significantly more expensive to buy than
the international average
there are currently
3713 people on the housing waiting list
in Trafford in the year ending 22-23 we
had 943 people who presented and were
accepted as homeless at the end of the
same period 145 children were in
temporary accommodation and there was a
general rise of 15 of people in
temporary accommodation in Trafford
compared to the previous Financial year
this development provides a further step
in the right direction on a Brownfield
site in a sustainable area the officer
report confirms that the benefits of the
scheme substantially outweigh any of the
negatives associated with the design of
the scheme and the vast majority of
objections to this scheme are in my view
not planning related and some are based
on nothing more than assumptions one of
the particular objection states that
social housing would become dominant in
this area
this is completely untrue at the last
ward profile the percentage of units in
urmston that were occupied by people
renting from a social landlord was 13 in
flexton the number was 10 this scheme
adds 12 units to the existing stock this
increases the number of socially rented
homes by less than the percentage point
90 of flexton's housing stock will
therefore not be social housing I would
also politely point out that part of the
reason we have a housing crisis in
Trafford and why so many people cannot
afford to buy or rent a home in this
area is precisely because we do not have
enough affordable housing I strongly
doubt we will ever have a situation
where social housing dominates the
tenure type in flixton but the fact is
any increase in this provision even as
small as this proposed development is
essential to tackling the housing crisis
there is a clear argument made and clear
evidence provided that this scheme more
than meets the criteria to be granted
planning permission the benefits of the
scheme outweigh any harm or resident
objection
many of the objections are simply
unsubstantiated arguing that this scheme
will bring so-called unsavory characters
to the area there is no evidence for
this whatsoever and the stereotypes
people the vast majority who live in
abject poverty as people we would not
want to associate with this is simply
not the case people become homeless for
many reasons a report in 2019 by shelter
the housing charity found that 45 of
private renters are one paycheck from
homelessness the figure increases to 65
for families with children this was in
2019 before the pandemic and before the
cost of living crisis the figure is
almost certainly higher now
this scheme seeks to provide
accommodation for people in our Borough
who do not have a home they do not have
a safe place to go they do not have a
warm secure and safe place to be
ah thank you Miss Coley before we bring
in the rest of the members
um could I go to the officers with some
comments on the points raised by the
speakers and we could go to the traffic
officer first for some of the points
rates around traffic and parking at the
Republican
thank you with regards to the car park
absolutely yeah the the car park doesn't
have a parking order
um it's not a designated car park it's
privately owned land
um people have been able to benefit from
parking on there but the the fact is it
could be taken away at any point
um it's not a car park for the football
club nor for any of the other clubs or
residents in the area
um it's understood that it was
previously leased to the golf club for
use by their members
so people parking there it's it's an
added benefit but it is not a car park
in terms of you know parking orders
um it hasn't been designated that way
it's not recognized by Trafford Parking
Services it's not managed by them
um and as I say it is not a formal car
park okay thank you how about the points
made about the um uh the
the effect the this would have on the
the or the general Traffic Safety around
the area
um and also there's there's a second
point which I think I read in the
reports is to do with the amount of car
parking land currently uses a car park
space which would actually be lost in
the events of the development being
approved thank you yeah
um with regards to pennybridge Lane
that's a definitive right-of-way a
public right-of-way it's classified as a
footpath path number two uh 22 I believe
um in urmston
um
if there is an obstruction
and the Emergency Services cannot get
down there
the in-law the police have the ability
to take action against the vehicles that
are causing the obstruction
if this is already taking place then it
may be that the police have been
involved I understand there was some
form of dispersal order issued some time
ago but that would need to be clarified
with them with regards to on-street
parking around the area
this has been brought up in other
planning applications we understand that
there's a high level of residence
parking across the area
um rather than commuters but the the
upshot of this one is we wouldn't expect
there to be a high ownership amongst the
residents of the proposed development so
far as Motor Vehicles are concerned
um and it's in a sustainable location
it's within walking distance of
Hermiston Town Center it's within
walking distance of public transport
links amenities Services
um and from a from a highways point of
view and a paragraph triple one of the
mppf
it's not considered that the residual
impact will be severe
and in terms of Highway Safety there are
no recorded personal engineering
collisions associated with this site
okay thank you every move to you Miss
Lowe's
um and the the comments I picked up from
the representations made by the
residents were around
um
there was a there was an odd there was
there was a comment made about uh the
the
uh the purpose of this changed halfway
through the planning process I've been
quite interested if you had any comment
on that
um and also just again a brief summary
of the way the Tilted balance was
arrived at if that's okay without going
through the full detail of the report
again thank you Mrs yes that's fine and
if if a major I'll just kind of clarify
a few points as well that were picked up
in terms of dimensions and things like
that yeah thank you I'll just do that
first if that's okay because I've just
got the plan up on and the screen I
think in a couple of the um comments
there were some discrepancies in terms
of the actual distances to the front
boundary the front elevation of the the
properties on on
um Shoreview so just to make that
completely clear exactly what we're
talking about there is a 7.5 meter
distance and that's from the front of
the um The Terraces and that's to the
boundary of the application site so you
can see that distance there I don't know
if my case is showing
on the um on the screen but what we do
have is a 15 meter distance from the
front elevation of the properties to the
two-story Gable and and that is in
accordance with our planning guidance in
terms of impacts on on residential
amenity so so that complies there and
then we have 11.5 meters to the single
story element of the development so just
to make that clear in terms of
dimensions and the relationship between
the proposed development and the um the
existing properties and I think another
Point picked up was around
um access and how and there's a number
of little access points from the car
park onto the um to the alleyway the
shared getting all along the front of
the property
whilst this development will close up
one or two of those access points a
number of those other access points will
remain but I think it's important to
note that there is no legal right of
access and from this site into into the
to the Alleyway that says sure View and
the mean access point is is from M Shaw
Road
um in terms of the point that you raised
chair about the the purpose and the
change I'm I'm not aware that there has
been any change through the app planning
application process I as I wasn't
involved
um when it was at the consultation stage
with msv and but as far as we've been
aware once the planning application was
um submitted and the eligibility
criteria was exactly as the the speaker
has set out that this is for um
residents who are
um experienced homelessness or or rough
sleepers who've been engaging with
um the a bed for every night scheme and
they've been engaging well with that
they have low level
um support needs and that this then
provides them with a
um two-year tenancy to allow them to
then gain payment and accommodation
should that be where they want to go and
following that and that's always been
the case from the from a planning
perspective through this planning
application
and the second point that you raise
shares about the Tilted balance
um and as as you'll all know as you read
through the report officers have raised
some
um concerns
um in relation to the design of the
development and
um identified some conflict with um
policy L7 in terms of the um the impact
on the the character of the of the wider
area and whilst that is recognized and
and there's a number of um
suggestions that we've made to the
applicant in order to address those they
haven't been forthcoming and but
whilst harm is identified and that harm
is there and is clearly reported in in
that officer report officers felt that
the very substantial weight that we've
afforded to the the the development in
the form of affordable homes at a social
rent for a very specialized need was was
such
for residents of Trafford to be
allocated by host and was something that
would outweigh those Harms in this
instance and there's a conditional a
condition is proposed on the permission
on the um decision to ensure that that
use is retained so it can only be used
for that purpose as is set out in the
eligibility criteria
um and on that basis officers felt that
you know as the balance is already
tilted towards grant that
um those harms wouldn't outweigh those
the benefits that we've identified and
that's why officers have recommended
approval
okay thank you Mr loves any member wish
to speak
Council callingly
um thank you chair
um before I make any comment can I nail
down this issue over parking
because
if I this is a correct move I'm wrong
there are no planning
Provisions to allow us to preserve
in the same way we would preserve
something of value car parking doesn't
fit into that does it that we cannot
preserve a car park
in that sense it cannot stay in
pituitary as a car park as a protected
space the same way we would protect
green bell or whatever it has no status
that's correct there's no policy there's
nothing in the development plan or
national policy let's talk about a
designated
that is not
something in terms of planning that is
about
Town Center management and things like
that so an NCP per car park for instance
would not be a designated car park if
NCP decided they couldn't make money on
that car park and lock the gates
Council wouldn't be able to force them
open
so in some ways
all that this is the issue that I I've
had I keep reading the the the the the
the most of the objections I know I want
to come back to Shoreview because I
think they've got legitimate objections
but the objection is about the car
parking
are not a problem for this committee You
could argue that a problem for James
writes as the executive member because
he's choosing to sell the land
and dispose of car parking but from this
committee's point of view the car
parking isn't an issue it's
we have an application to build on a car
park
and that car park is something we can't
Preserve
so we have to look at the application to
build on its merits on its own merits
not on the loss of the car parking is
that fair
yes I think
the council could hoard off the land
tomorrow and there's nothing anybody
could do about it yeah
so the car parking isn't an issue for
this so we're left with an application
to build
now I have
didn't like the report to be honest I
disagreed with quite a lot where the the
where the report was critical of the
application
I was quite positive I think it does go
with the gray I look at the map and it
is it this new development is in line
with most of the streets that come off
flixton road
it is ingrained with that neighborhood I
didn't think that was a particular issue
and it's interesting there's no
objections on the The Styling of the
build nobody said oh it's an ugly
building and he's out of context with
the neighbor I don't think it is and I
quite like the pattern of the doors
despite the the officer saying that's
wrong and it's not neat and tidy where I
do have a problem is the closeness to
Sure View and I can't get
and it's one of those where if I could
shunt this whole development
three meters to the South it would delay
all my worries over if you could just do
that and move it further south towards
the
and leave things as they were and leave
the Landscaping along the alleyway as it
was I'd be totally happy I'm not totally
happy with that seven foot brick wall
that's on the alleyway that's going to
face about six proper six properties is
it is round It Centers on number 26
anyway
um not totally happy with that but I
don't think I can I don't like it if I
could vote against that wall I would but
I don't think I can I don't think
I don't think it's unreasonable I think
we're creating an enclosed alley where
at the moment it's open and he's got
trees alongside it and Shoreview is very
unique in that it doesn't have a road in
front of it so I think that Alleyway is
important
but
there's nothing there's nothing in
planning that protects that and that's a
difficulty for me I'll be interested in
hearing what other people say about that
wall
the 15 meters from the
um the the front of Shoreview to the um
Gable end also bothers me because I
believe the limit is 15 meters so it's
exactly and that all I always get I
don't like people pushing things right
to the the limit that's as close as that
Gable end can get and still meet
planning
which means it's tight
but I'm struggling to be able to vote
against it because planning says you can
be 15 meters away
um and so planning is saying that I can
I have to
there's no objection to that so I've got
problems with and I did the the people
that live in those 20 numbers uh the 20s
of Shoreview I have real sympathy I
don't think this is ideal for them for
the for the users of the car park I have
sympathy but it's not for this planning
committee you know I just don't think it
is I think we should just be focusing on
the building
um
and I'm minded because I I mean at the
moment I I will have to vote for it
because I don't have a planning reason
to vote against it but I'll be
interested to hear what other people say
thank you okay thank you counselor uh
councilor actually
thank you
um
I wanted to get a better understanding
of why the playing officers feel they
support design quality just for my own
understanding really and maybe for
others interests
um
I also wanted to
understand more about the path to the
rear of the properties at the north side
of the development and whether there is
any access to that path
in the middle of it rather than just the
other side
um
one thing that I wanted to clarify as
well was point three of the conditions
um
you mentioned to be occupied by
households or individuals in housing
need and should not be offered to say a
lot of events on the open market however
on point three I or one
um if States a tenant has exercised the
right to require right to buy or
anything similar statutory provision
and for the avoidance of Doubt once such
right to acquire our right to buy has
been exercised the proprietor of the
property mortgagee and subsequent
Proprietors and their mortgages shall be
permitted to sell or rent the property
on the open market so that that on the
face of it concerns me because I would
like this development to be strictly for
those who are homeless or at risk of
being homeless I think it'd be a real
shame and probably like an outrage for
local residents if
is initially for homeless people or
those struggling
to find homes but then they just convert
into your standard properties that
people buy with you know help to buy or
whatever else so I wanted to get a
better understanding of that and the
protections for this scheme to be purely
for those who are at risk of becoming um
homeless or are already homeless
um and that's that's it thank you Miss
Lowe's if you would I'll be grateful
I will
um Miss Lowe's will deal with everything
else I know the answer to the question
about the affordable housing um you
cannot remove the statutory right to buy
or right to acquire
um via a planning condition
um that has to remain in law so that
provision has to go in because a tenant
of social housing is does have that
right it's unlikely here because of the
the condition requiring it to be
homeless move on accommodation in in
that two years
um stepping up into a into another
property and it's unlikely that they
would have the funds to then be able to
buy buy the premises
um but we absolutely can't rule that out
but that would be the case for any
affordable housing scheme in the borough
in fact in the country you can't take
that right away
so that's that by national law rather
than by yeah
thank you
it's my understanding that tenants of
former Council social housing so tenants
of lnq if they were tenants while it was
still owned by Trafford Council they
still have the right to buy but that new
tenants don't have that same right to
buy
I don't know the answer that I'm afraid
counselor
so thank you okay and so on the design
issues I think um
paragraph 43 in the report kind of um
sets that out but what I think the main
the main concern that officers have is
that
the position and the sighting of the
development is at odds with the
terrorists by being perpendicular to the
um the existing terrorists it doesn't
follow that natural Urban green
um in a perfect world and in a perfect
solution would be that the two Terraces
would face onto each other or be you
know back to back or you would you would
see them like that so in in officers
Minds that would be the solution and
what I think
um
part of the problem is that it sits
perpendicular with a brick wall that
would be and be highly visible within
the street scene from pennybridge Lane
and
whilst being part of
um this existing open space that's
currently used for for car parking so
that's that's kind of the Crux of the
the kind of sighting issue and I think
the other the other issues that I picked
up are around the um the actual the
treatments of the elevations the the
individual entrance doors
um for each of the units so you've got
12 entrance doors instead of maybe six
um and the you know the meter boxes and
things like that that add clutter and
whilst they're recognized that there's a
there's a we when we spoke to the
applicant there was a need to have those
individual doors to give individual
ownership to each of those units and
that's recognized and understood but in
in pure design teams we consider that to
to be overly an overly clotted
elevational treatment and so that that's
the point in terms of the the the design
and the issues that that officers have
raised in terms of show of you
um and so you're talking about the if I
can just go on to the aerial view yeah
it's just the representation is made
around access and any disabled or pram
uses things that is much difficult for
them and is there any access or will
there be any access provided can it be a
condition
okay so I I think my own I've got I
prepared a slide to try and show some
photographs of this
um
so I think as you can see on this um
on this image there's a number of access
points
um off the car park into that Alleyway
um I think this is this is the one
particular that residence
um suggested was was
um the most level for um pram users and
and maybe people who have got mobility
issues but there's a number of other
access points um along some of the some
steps and some of that individual access
points the majority of those will remain
and the the application and will only
sit in front of four residential units
and in that in that um in that Terrace
and that access will remain there is
access to the rear offshore view of this
kind of like a track that leads to the
rear of the properties and the
properties I think it's 22 to 38 or 26
to 38 they've got rear back Gardens as
well so there's this access at the rear
from there and then there's an access
point into the alleyway offshore road
that Lee that gives Direct accessing it
looks like the historic access to the
alleyway
thank you Miss Lowe's Council Maitland
I hope this isn't a death question but
why can't it just be moved down the car
park a little bit why is it sitting
where it is
that's the scheme the applicant has put
before us
is there no negotiation where it can be
moved please ask the applicant to move
it into various different places and in
different in a different sighting and
this is the scheme that we have from the
applicants
this is the scheme that we've got in
front of us if any negotiation was going
to take place it would take place
outside of this committee okay thank you
thanks chair
um this is turned into a very very
complicated
um
application Council accordingly lost me
there about about the car park I tried
my best
it's more strategic than me uh Mike
he lost me there to me that's a car park
it looks like a car park people treat
like a car park I've been going in and
out there doing things for years it's
the car park as far as I'm concerned
if this application wasn't talking about
uh
homeless accommodation
talking about
people are going to be there for two
years and I think Mrs Smith wanted to to
bottom that out I think the councilor in
today as well you know is it is it
permanent is it two years and then you
move what what's the nature of it I
don't think that's been bottomed out yet
if this was a normal planning
application where people would have
you know we're building these uh this
accommodation for people to buy to go on
the open market
it would not last two seconds in this
planning committee we would throw it out
that's a fact of life
and the DSi won't even get to the
planning committee because the officers
would have said you're not having this
this is ridiculous
I've got to say I do not like this
application
I hear what the residents have said and
I think there are genuine concerns that
they've expressed perhaps some of them
are not planning reasons
but I went down the other day and it
literally is building
properties on a car park now where what
where do we stop
where do we say this are we going to
build houses out on the town hall cap
because we're desperate for how is an
accommodation I've had people ringing me
up this week and all the counselors have
heard me say this many a Time
people are desperate for somewhere to
live in traffic there's a house
insurance all you people down there no
you will have friends and family who've
got nowhere to live and they're
struggling and that's why there's this
pressure on particularly in traffic to
build properties
we're desperate you know our house
prices are so large it's difficult to
get onto the market and there's a
genuine charge people are desperate but
I think we talk about tilted balance
I think it's tilted the other way here I
think we've we're sacrificing we're
destroying that area it's beautiful to
show for you it is it's not I'm not
telling lies it's a beautiful spot we're
going to destroy that for these 12
properties for this social housing and
all the members on this committee the
people who've been here more than two or
three years will know how strongly I
feel about social housing
but I think it's gone too far this I
think someone said it's it's ill thought
out you know should we build it on the
town or care but what about Tesco's what
about here what about with disability
housing that's where it's going that's
where this conversation is going
and and one thing that I'd say the
residents and I think fairly have talked
about their concerns you know
they've lived there all this time why
can't they enjoy what they've had that
was it's councilor Thomas said we talk
about the immunity of the residents that
are there we're obviously we're
concerned about the new people are going
to move in there but what about the
amenity of the residents that were there
already and I think we do them a
disservice with this application and
the reasons for refusal well they're in
various I got them
I've got it written written down here on
pages 21 28 and 41. the reason even the
officers are saying about the poor
design Miss O'Connor didn't talk about
the design being good Council
accordingly likes the design I don't
like the design and the officers don't
like the design and they've had some
they've had to drag the they have to say
it they've had to track drag those
designers over the coals to change them
to get what they've got now it doesn't
fit in it's out of keeping and that's
why that petition's come up
so I will be voting against this chair I
hear what I'm interested in obviously on
what other people say but uh is it and
it's a big change for me this I do
really support socialize button this the
Tilted balance has gone too far the
other way I'll be voting against
supplications here thank you
yeah thank you thank you councilor I
mean my view on this is oh before I
weighed in uh thank you chair I'm
probably gonna talk for a while I'm
sorry
yeah what's new
I've got two separate views on this
[Music]
so I'll go around my first one
for a number of years me and the other
councilor Proctor headed up our homeless
work for our church by nav Manchester
we spent
Mondays Wednesdays Fridays on the
streets of Manchester talking to the
mainly men
but some women who called the streets
their home
we fed and watered them we took them
clothing shoes coats
sleeping bags whatever they asked us for
and tried to move them into
hostels
and what I learned which I knew already
in theory but what I learned was
we're all one step away from being
homeless
we're all one step away from making a
wrong decision
or something happening to us out of our
control
and especially now in
the crisis that we're facing as a
country with people
in insecure employment
using food banks it's gone up massively
so easily we could tip over from being
a homeowner or someone living in the
rented sector
to not being able to afford to pay our
rent
or our mortgage
and then we end up homeless
through no fault of our own
maybe we try couch surfing
moving in with friends for a bit but
they get sick of us and we end up
homeless
and where'd you go
where do you go to live and some of the
stories of the people
we would meet week in week out
told us it was a spiraling down
from a mistake
or from a circumstance out of their
control and they ended up sleeping rough
the people who would be moving into
this set of flats
are people who've already moved off the
streets
and have been living in hostels
are supported accommodation and then
would be moved
now
there's lots of research about who who
are rough sleepers a third of them
and this is on average a third of them
are care leavers
a third of them are from our Armed
Forces
and yes a third of them are ex-offenders
but those ex-offenders they're not all
pedophiles they're not all murderers
they're not all
people who've committed acts of violence
to end up in jail
and that's who we're talking about it's
really People Like Us it could be any of
my foster kids
it could be my friend who was a
helicopter pilot in in the RAF
it's could so easily be any of us and so
I take deep offense when I read
oh we don't want these people here
these people they're actually us
it's not these people
so that's my one View
my other View
this sucks
really does it's so close to those
houses and
so that this
group of terraces used to be my ward
when I was Affliction counselor and it's
a path
but you go down I go down on my mobility
scooter and I would knock on all these
all these people's doors and chat to
them
and it's a beautiful little gem
and I do not understand why Moss curse
and Vincent
wants to put
these 12 Flats
right next to them when there's a dirty
great big
space they could use now I grew up
around here
I remember when it was it wasn't a
concrete or a Tarmac car park it was a
cinder car park it's been a car park
or used as a car park it's been a piece
of wasteland used for virtually all my
life
so I get work Council Walsh is coming
from as well
we need this type of accommodation in
Trafford we absolutely need it
but what we don't need is it's sitting
on top of
a lovely Terrace and when there's that
and when I've looked at sorry I have to
take my glasses off when I've looked at
the
um
area it's going to take up
it could go anywhere in that car park
it's a bit misleading that it's
um p-shaped because part of the Pea the
top is just grass
nearly yeah there that bit's just grass
it's actually L-shaped it's not p-shaped
it could move right down to to the other
end of the car park
and I think what we should be doing is
saying to Moscow Vincent
we liked this concept
we don't like where you've put it
and we'd like you to come back with an
improved plan
thank you chair
ah thank you thank you councilor uh
my view on this is it revolves around
the two things one is whether this is
really a car park or not and it's not
it's been used it has been used as a car
park for a substantial amount of time
but it's not a car park uh actually
three things like this come down to is
the the other thing is is this as bad a
design as uh people have said around the
table I don't think so I don't think it
is a I don't think it is a bad design
I also look at the way I interacts with
the current Shoreview uh for sure viewed
um
Terrace and
I know the separation distance is 7.5
meters I don't think it would be
overbearing
I don't I don't think it will be
overbearing for the to the Terrace so
the way I'm feeling at the moment is on
balance and on reading the officers
reports is to come down in favor
of the officer's recommendation to
approve
does any other member wish to speak
Captain Jerome
thanks chair I won't speak for too long
because I'll probably only repeat what's
been said already because I think there
is a kind of consensus on this committee
I think most people are uncomfortable
with this planning application and I I
think Council accordingly got it totally
right you know where are the planning
reasons to object to this that that's
probably where we're struggling here and
it's not a designated car park and
therefore that's not a planning reason
so we are struggling but I also thought
it was interesting in the air report
that these houses have been dated
wrongly in the report too there are
actually 50 or 60 years older than it
says in the report and I think that just
shows the fabric of these houses to the
area they're kind of
probably
they they when this area started these
houses were built and that's why that's
so important I almost think again I'm
disappointed like Council accordingly
was a report that our heritage doesn't
recognize that these are actually a
Heritage asset in my my opinion but but
because Heritage says they're not they
were non-des they're not a
non-designated Heritage asset we can't
use that as an argument so again we're
struggling for planning reasons to
object to this
um and I just kind of feel there's a
consensus here we all want to object to
it but we're struggling for the planning
reasons and it'd be interesting to hear
councilor Walsh's reasons for refusal
yeah
um if members consider that an
undesignated Heritage asset
um provided you can reason that that
that's a beauty you are entitled to take
okay I've almost councilman did you wish
to speak
um I'm I'm just wondering is I
understand this is the application
that's put before us
um is a discussion of whether was that
the plot of land they were sold
effectively to build on is that the
possible land they've been given or has
the whole
the whole not a car park being
um
you know offered because then it could
end up in somewhere else couldn't sit
rather than being in the place it
clearly
irritates everybody
um I'm just that that's my question is
is it because it has to be there because
that's the bit that they've been given
by the council or not checking or that's
the question we can answer for the
opposite can we or can we answer
no okay that'd be great yes my
understanding is that's the case that's
the piece of land that they've bought
the rest of the car park or the piece of
land remains in Council ownership or
they haven't bought it that's the piece
of land they are
um proposing to buy because what it does
is it gives you access to these
properties from the Shoreview M Road
adjacent to the residential care home
and that's that access that would save
these properties and and that's what you
benefit from that particular piece of
land and that's my understanding okay
thank you do you have any more remarks
councilor
no okay now with they've allowed an
awful lot of time oh Council recklessly
sorry I know it's been going on for a
while just final remarks
I was I was going to vote in favor of
this actually but after following
councilor Walsh's remarks I've I've
really
um bounced about a bit in my head around
it I think with the comments around it
being a car car park
for me that doesn't really matter it
could be brownfield's site I think there
are other issues on the planning level
that are found within this development
um that the planning officers have
identified and Council the horses
identified as well
um I would be willing to consider it an
undesignated site
um it also appears to me that from
comments made by planning officers that
the developer has
not worked as freely as they could have
done with the planning officers to
perhaps decide on a different patch of
car park that would be more in keeping
maybe in parallel with the Shoreview
Terraces maybe in some kind of format
that isn't as overbearing and perhaps
um not giving those
um design concerns that the planning
officers have identified
so yeah
um
I think strictly on planning grounds
disregarding the car park
I'm following Council of Walsh's
comments I feel like I'm going to vote
against unfortunately and and if it
wasn't for being a homeless
development
you know I wouldn't have a problem
voting against
thank you Council I think after him
hearing the debate and I think this is
a hugely complicated
um application in front of us I'm
willing to make a proposal I wanted to
make a proposal which will allow the
planning officers to have further
conversations with the applicant to see
if this can be improved so I wanted to
propose that we defer a decision on this
second okay so because I was about to
propose the same thing okay brilliant so
we got a proposal to
um to defer
yeah of course you can
I totally agree with the decision mind
but one of the things I would like to
look at is this question of
non-designated uh asset and I would like
it to include the alleyway if possible I
think the alleyway is really important
in its own right
as it's
it's Unique in in many ways so that's a
suggestion to make to the officers when
they're looking at the yes the Heritage
asset that's something to take into
account yeah yeah I don't know whether
you can designate an Alleyway but it's
important we have a nod that it could
take you can be taken apart we
partnering part of the mix
Heritage asset can include an access way
or Road
there are no there are plenty of
um non-designated roads
but it does depend on significance we
would want our heritage officer to look
look at that a bit further and if we
return the application to the committee
we would probably have some explanation
as to to where officers have got on that
okay so it's been proposed a second and
that we don't counselor Russian
I generally don't object the uh any
planning for the Housing Association
because we need more and more roses and
this particularly uh these Flats were
coming for the homeless people that's
fine
what that means not at the cost of the
existing
the vicinity of the people that is
living there it has made me very
difficult to make
to go ahead with this application to be
honest so it is good to go ahead as a
defer so they come back again with other
proposals
yeah thank you so that's that's the
sentiment of the committee that's why
we're about to take a vote on deferring
this so well that's my favor of
deferring the decision
yeah
are you voting counselor
okay
all those roads and against the decision
for the deferral that's two that's we're
voted to uh defer that particular
decision thank you members
uh the next item on the agenda is
is uh Woods End Road which I'll hand
over to councilor Walsh to chair thank
you
yeah
okay everybody
um the next item is on page one sixty
Woods End Road flixton and Miss laws is
going to give us an introduction to this
application
thank you councilor
um this application relates to the site
at 60 woodens Road flixton
and relates to the existing Gymnastics
Center that's situated on the east side
of the road and as you can see on the um
aerial view located here behind
um Residential Properties fronting the
Main Street the applicant seeks planning
permission to vary condition three of
the original brand of permission which
was allowed on appeal to extend the
hours of use on Saturdays and Sundays
currently the hours of use are 8 A.M
till midday on a Saturday and 10 a.m
till midday on a Sunday The Proposal
seeks to increase this from 8 A.M till 5
PM on Saturdays and 10 a.m to 4 P.M on
Sundays and bank holidays
this application is reported to planning
committee
because there are six or more letters of
objection country to officer
recommendation
the key issues for consideration are if
there are any potential impacts on
residential amenity and highways or
parking
the proposed extended hours are you
views are within daytime hours and not
in the times when the sleep of occupiers
could be disturbed or when a fruit a
noise free environment would generally
be experienced as in accordance with the
inspector's comments within the previous
appeal decision the applicant has
submitted a noise management strategy
which has been reviewed by the
environmental health offices of the
council and they are satisfied with its
content and raised no objections it is
considered that the additional hours of
use on a Saturday and Sunday only would
not have any unacceptable impact on
residential amenity through noise or
disturbance or on highway safety over
and above the current consented use and
hours of operation this is subject to
the further imposition of the conditions
attached to the original Grant of
planning permission and those extended
hours of use are considered acceptable
The Proposal is considered to be in
accordance with the development plan and
as such the application is recommended
for approval subject to conditions thank
you
thank you Miss Lowe's
um we've got a statement by Miss charity
James is going to be written a written
statement and Miss Cole is going to read
that too as Miss Coley
I hereby make know my concerns regarding
this application as a directly affected
neighbor in the community one parking
congestion people parking on Pavements
without due regard for residents
disabled accessibility and pedestrians
the residents with disabilities in the
in the vicinity and it is so unfair for
users to park without due care for them
due to this ongoing unfair parking
habits there are near Mrs Collision
Collision due to blind spots observed as
people begin to rush out after sessions
without due care for ongoing traffic two
littering there seems to be more than
the usual littering since these
activities ensued lots of letters left
behind in their tray bottles cans wraps
papers which are not acceptable and may
cause infestation of rats Etc on my
property the environment at large three
privacy and noise I'm a bit concerned
for privacy as the area will be
attracting a lot of Outsiders which in
turn cannot be controlled I've seen a
couple of people overlooking to my
property and this makes me feel unsafe
also there are louder than the necessary
noise due to this heavy traffic
developing as a result of the activities
four observation of the environment
before granting the application based on
settled tweets can the council officer
in charge come down to an observe
without announcing they're coming to see
for themselves the concerns and points
are being raised because it's all well
and good calling For A Meeting Planners
without you actually experiencing the
challenges you are not able to make an
informed decision so an unannounced
visit will enable the council official
to observe and say the problems and
challenges firsthand
thank you for your continuing support of
the community and careful consideration
of applicants applications that might
cause inconvenience for the elderly in
the community
thank you
thank you Miss Coley and um we've got a
written statement from the applicant
Joel Brown It's called
good evening chair evening members I'm
Joe owner of fusion gymnastics and the
head coach at the center I've run this
business for the past three years at the
center I'm passionate about providing
opportunities for children to learn
important life skills in a safe
environment this involves children from
the age of three learning vital skills
in their early development through to
older children seeking to build their
confidence improve their skills and
provide a place to make friends and
encourage A Healthy Start in life
the national planning policy framework
recognizes the decisions should aim to
achieve healthy inclusive and safe
places which enable and support Healthy
Lifestyles especially where this would
address identified local health and
well-being needs for example through the
provision and safe accessible sports
facilities in restricting the hours of
use and refusing this application would
go against the aims of the framework
traffic Council Public Health have
identified five priorities for Trafford
Public Health the first being two being
key the first aim is to reduce the
impact on Mental Health exercise is key
to this especially crucial for young
children in recent years and secondly to
reduce physical inactivity something I
strive to encourage through providing an
enjoyable way to keep active the skills
in gymnastics the movement the muscles
which are developed are valuable in
every sport we don't have to look far to
see a club excelling and what they do in
sport in the form of Manchester City
I've been involved in coaching their
youth teams at their facilities as they
recognize the key role these skills hold
for development
I've been operating at the site with the
hours now proposed and knowingly in the
breach of the condition however if these
hours are reduced this reduces my
ability to deliver these opportunities
to Children classes will have to be
canceled and the number of children I
can pass on my passion to will be
severely restricted given school hours
the need to have more availability at
the weekends is key not only for the
sake of the children but to enable me to
run a viable business which I have
dedicated the last 15 years into making
a success managing to navigate through
the tough years that businesses like
mine have suffered in recent times
you will note from the officer report
that there'll be no objection to
statutory consulties including the
Environmental Protection nuisance
officer whilst the revised hours would
increase only in terms of the conditions
I do not consider as is agreed by the
professional planning officer that this
increase would result in an unacceptable
impact on amenity we do not hold outdoor
events the only noise generators from
the arrival at departure and classes
however this is not excessive as some of
the neighbor comets have referenced we
are close to an existing Park would send
where children visit and often have
football fixtures which is my view given
the locations from where some of the
objections have been received is that
some of the noise generated may not even
be related to the operations of the gym
given the structure of classes which
provides requires people to be booked
onto specific lessons which lasts
between 90 minutes they're not a regular
flow of comings and goings from the site
which in itself limits the impact of the
operations
I'm passionate about providing children
with opportunities hoping to encourage
an active start in life that they will
carry into adulthood are respectively
respectfully request that you support
the officer recommendation for which no
statutory objections are being raised
and support my application many thanks
thank you Miss Coley any members wishing
to comment
please thank you thank you chair I fully
support this application to be honest
and the children has
the right of learning and environment
Mental Health and Social Health to go
out and enjoy I mean it has already been
a place where the people been going
throughout the week so why not on the
weekend if there is any Transportation
issue and and then fully support this
application
I mean if it's not any you know the
transportation encroachment or any issue
on the weekends that's that's fine it's
a good application to receive I will
fully support this
anybody else councilor Maitland
one second that support as well as
second uh supporting this application
um it would send us lost so much
um there's no use Club there's hardly
anything down there if we lose this as
well and I know it's this lady's
business but you know it's it's what we
need
um so I'm sure if there's a problem with
litter uh that Ms Brown could maybe sort
out that sort of thing with the parents
and parking I think we've already
addressed the parking in that area but
as said
it might not be anything to do with the
families picking up from there it could
be the symbol that's going on or the the
the park users Etc so
um I'll be supporting this cue anybody
else Council Jerome
thanks chair I think I'd probably Echo
what councilor Maitland has just said
that when you look at the
representations many of them are to do
with the parking issues in the
surrounding area and I kind of fully
appreciate what the residents say at
many areas are beset by parking problems
these days and hordes of cars turning up
you know for football matches and that
kind of thing and inconsiderate behavior
that comes off the back of that so what
I fully understand what they're saying
and I'm sure that they feel that this
might add to it slightly but I don't
think it's really enough to object to
this planning application which is
overall seems like a sound one
um there's quite a few issues here like
lighting which I think aren't really a
problem at all aren't mentioned in the
objections so um yeah I'll be supporting
the proposal okay anybody else
can I ask about the children's parties
um it said it says in the report that
they'll take place on an ad hoc basis
um but I didn't see anything on the uh
in the conditions about that it so how
do if they occurred every week what what
would happen then
and yes councilor well what we've what
we consider and what the report sets out
is that we believe it's ancillary so
it's a use that is um ancillary to the
to the existing gym use so we don't
consider that it needs to be conditioned
in any way it just forms a part of the
the existing use and would be a small
element of of the um of the the
gymnastics centers
um
schedules going going forward
[Music]
I think that's it I'd like to we
proposing a second I think um
proposed by councilor San seconded by
Council of Maitland all those in favor
of granting this application please show
and those against that's unanimous the
application's been granted
can we ask for a counselor the chair to
come back in councilor when Stanley
please
uh thank you councilor if we now move on
to the last item on the agenda which is
111079 1662 Green Drive In timperley on
page 51 of the park and Miss Coley will
give the introduction thank you Miss
Kelly thank you this application relates
to a two-story somebody's attached
property on the north side of Green
Drive in a residential area of timberley
the application proposes the erection of
a two-story side and rear extension
following the demolition of the existing
garage the applications received no
objections however it is before the
committee tonight because the applicant
is a member of the council the key
issues for consideration are the
proposals design impact on the character
the street scene impact on residential
immunity and Highway strip parking in
packs The Proposal whilst large is
considered to be appropriate within the
context in the scale of plot designed
the proposal and character the street
scene with many properties already
benefiting from two-story side
extensions The Proposal is considered to
be in accordance with a development plan
as such the application is recommended
for approval subject to conditions thank
you
uh thank you Miss curly we have no
speakers on this tonight anybody wish to
speak counseling accordingly
and the formalities yeah um it fits him
in the street scene uh even the house
opposite has a very at number 33 I think
has a very similar Arrangement it would
be completely incongruous of us to
refuse it
um
I'm going to tell her off for having a
drive that covers so much of a front
garden but other than that I think we
should welcome this plan yes so I I'm
proposed thank you so it felt like a
proposal a counselor Hassan then
councilor Proctor
or the other way around second
okay brilliant anybody else Mr Speaker
Mike yeah Mike Mike still
thank you
um councilor Brian
um declared an interest and he's he's
not taking part of the meeting I'm not
sure perhaps we should all declare an
interest Checkers councilor of Gilbert
is known to all of us and uh and usually
in the past when these have come up with
we've declared a blanket uh declaration
yeah and maybe but I suspect until you
said that not everybody realized
he was um it was uh councilor Gilbert
you kind of gave it away Mike okay well
I'm happy that's everybody wish to
declare a blanket interest because we
know councilor Gilbert
yeah go on then yeah
okay members so we've now had it um
proposed and second into that we accept
this all those in favor
I'll make that unanimous thank you
uh arrives in the absence so I don't
think there's any any urgent business so
I conclude the meeting over thank you
members thank you
thank you